what's the point of nuclear weapons if
we never get to use them
well okay we did once in 1945 we killed
tens of thousands of people in japan
with two atomic bombs but that was a
one-off right
an extreme situation no actually
did you know there was an active plan to
nuke mainland china too as in
the highest levels of the us government
were planning for an imminent attack
just about 60 years ago
thankfully president eisenhower stepped
in and said it probably wasn't a good
idea
that's the story that's come to light as
a still classified 1966 government study
published online
is getting increasing attention the
unredacted pages show how the us was
thinking about responding to china in
1958
when beijing began shelling island under
the control
of the newly founded republic of china
also known as taiwan
and which happens to be a u.s ally if
you comb
through you'll read that u.s military
officials quote felt that the use of
atomic weapons was inevitable
and quote the chairman of the joint
chief suggested that this move
would almost certainly involve nuclear
retaliation from the soviet union
but if national policy is to defend the
offshore islands then the consequences
had to be accepted imagine that
the consequences of a nuclear war that
could have killed millions of people
here and abroad
would just have to be accepted as
collateral damage
in a confrontation with communist china
this shocking disclosure was quietly
made public in 2017
by none other than daniel ellsberg who
is now so worried about a looming
conflict
that he wants to share the documents and
the revelations with a wider audience
the former military analyst served as a
special assistant to the defense
department during the vietnam war
and 50 years ago next month leaked the
pentagon papers a classified government
study
that as the ap put it chronicles
deception and misadventure
by the us in vietnam ellsberg made
copies of that top secret
study about the 1958 taiwan crisis at
the same time as he did the pentagon
papers
and now given that headlines here and
abroad are using the w word when it
comes to u.s china relations
ellsberg is hoping people and officials
in government pay close attention
to what escalating tensions with china
nearly led to
in the past given he almost went to
prison last time he did this
is ellsberg at the age of 90 ready
himself to go up against the government
again danny ellsberg
joins me now daniel thanks so much for
coming on the show
you held onto these documents for
decades and put them online in 2017
they're now getting more attention why
did you wait this long daniel and why do
you think now is the right time
to be discussing the fact that the us
almost dropped a nuke on china
you know the truth is that i was
prepared to
release what i had the uh on nuclear war
planning
as soon as the vietnam war had ended i
wanted
to do what i could to end that war
before i
brought up before i went to prison again
for uh
on different grounds for putting out the
nuclear documents
and when i wrote what a draft
of what is now the first third of my
recent book
uh the doomsday machine confessions of a
nuclear war planner
i submitted that to a publisher my
saying publisher
had published an earlier book papers on
the war uh
back in 1975 soon as the war had ended
and her attitude of the editor was
this will sell 1400 copies
and i said well that's one for every
member of congress and a lot of press
fine she said no you don't understand
what i mean
that means we don't publish it and
indeed i did try to get that word out
at various times the public doesn't want
to hear
didn't want to hear and for except for a
brief interval in the early 80s
when uh physicians for social
responsibility were making people aware
of what a one megaton bomb would do to
their cities
uh for once that's the only period in
that 50-year period
when people had a really real sense of
what thermonuclear war actually meant
that went away and when the cold war
ended they thought the problem is over
but the weapons are still there the
plans
the threats of initiating nuclear wear
first use
are still being made on both sides by
the way now about the russians as well
as the us
and daniel so
so on that note you mentioned the plans
are there the bombs are there you're
often asked about being a whistleblower
but
really by training by experience you are
a military analyst an expert on nuclear
strategy
in your new york times interview you
said quote i do not believe the
participants of this plan to attack
china with a nuclear bomb
were more stupid or thoughtless than
those in between or in the current
cabinet when you look at the current u.s
government the biden administration
people like secretaries blinken and
austin
how worried are you that some people
today really might want a war with china
that we may
inch near towards nuclear catastrophe
again
those are uh two different things in a
way because i think there are very few
people
who actually want a war with china
and certainly not a nuclear war and yet
they're prepared to gamble
to sort of poke at the bear in the cage
or something you know to show
our anti-china attitudes our cold war
attitudes and that
neither democrats nor republicans are
soft on china
that they're actually taking uh stands
here
um that actually could bring about war
and that
very likely would be nuclear war over
china over taiwan
as it was in 1958 it was when i read
some of those headlines you just put on
a month ago
that i thought wait a minute this uh
people have to realize what they're
talking about when they're talking about
war with a nuclear state china and
especially
accepting the idea of nuclear war which
is
insane
but i wonder what the stakes are for you
personally we all know releasing
classified documents is against the law
there's a possibility that doj could
come after you under the espionage act
for doing this which
you're kind of hoping for i believe so
you can challenge the doj's practice
of using that act to go after
whistleblowers you want to take on this
risk
so what is your game plan exactly what
are you hoping will happen
i hope that people on the one hand on
the
on the trial there's no question that
what i've just done
is as indictable as in the eyes of their
justice department which i think is on a
wrong track here
in the view of our first amendment but
in terms of the
prosecutions they've brought in the last
20 years especially starting with obama
oddly enough
and into trump and now into biden who is
still
pursuing uh the extradition of julian
assange
the fact is julian assange did that as a
publisher
like the new york times in publishing
this there is no basis for
for indicting um julian assange that
doesn't exist for the new york times
not only with what he put out but what i
just put out
that's i am not inviting an indictment
of new york times i think that would be
bad for this country but i am willing to
risk some indictment of myself
and you're a brave man for saying so in
doing so you mentioned the assange
extradition and the biden administration
you said in a recent interview with the
intercept
that i didn't start leaking i was the
first probably to do a mass release
and i wanted much more of that to happen
as a result more has happened of course
you know chelsea manning and edward
snowden
julian assange reality winner the list
goes on but manning spent
seven years in prison assange as he
published as you say is facing
extradition
winner is still in prison snowden won't
return from russia unless he's able
to argue a public interest defense he
says to a jury which the current
espionage act
does not allow for and which joe biden
supports as you say
do you believe there is an ongoing war
on whistleblowers including from
liberals
yes one has to say that
it was president obama who campaigned
on transparency in government and did
not deliver
on that at all in fact he indicted and
prosecuted
three times as many cases as
all previous presidents put together now
that earlier period was a small number
because it really violates our first
amendment it violates the constitution
but nevertheless he bought eight or nine
or ten depending how you count some of
these like general petraeus
uh as a whistleblower even for simply
giving
higher than top secret information much
higher
uh the highest we have covert identities
of covert agents
in a document he gave to his uh
by verbal biography for him he got a
slap on the wrist for that
now what i'm saying is that there's no
question that if you're going to indict
petraeus like well he didn't publish
actually he wanted his biographer to
publish when he didn't do it
but uh reality winner who i think was a
whistleblower here
very definitely in prison now the others
you mentioned ed snowden in permanent
exile
uh the uh for me of course at 90
uh the prospect of a sentence such as i
faced
in 1971 which was 115 years in prison or
assange is faced with right now 175
years
in prison a life sentence that doesn't
mean the same for me at 90 as it means
for them
not that i want to go in prison at all
but in a way
for 50 years it has been my retirement
plan
and we don't we don't want to see you in
prison
at the retirement blood or otherwise one
last question before i let you go
you know we're living in a very
different we're living in a very
different
uh era from when you released the
pentagon papers back in 1971.
when you look at the us today uh so
polarized so divided
uh people in their own information
bubbles uh in
social media silos do you think a modern
day version of the pentagon papers
would have have the same impact today or
would it simply be dismissed
by partisans who don't like the fact it
doesn't fit their
political narratives or identities
maybe when you say that uh about the
great difference from now
i have to tell you about a time when you
were very young i'd take it but in 1971
this country was polarized about the
pentagon about the vietnam war
and i was called a traitor uh by very
very widely
though not by the justice department
because treason is a very narrowly
defined in the constitution and i didn't
i didn't fit that but uh as of today
it's a very good we are still making
the threat of insane actions the threat
of nuclear attack
uh the first use of nuclear attack to
initiate nuclear war
in a variety of circumstances we've made
that commitment to a lot of allies
and we're in process the themes of
treating
of taiwan which the chinese regard
as part of china but we're we're in the
process of moving toward
regarding them as having the same
promise that we make to nato
of initiating nuclear war in their
defense that's the
promise of an insane attack a promise of
an insane response and
it's i think that needs
yes there should there should be
discussion there should be debate it's
insane to be threatening nuclear war
over anything
daniel ellsberg we appreciate you coming
on the show
releasing these documents being willing
to take on prison
and we thank you for everything you've
done throughout your career thank you so
much
appreciate it hi
i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching